this morning we're taking a look back at
a tragedy that changed the las vegas
strip forever it is this
the devastating fire 40 years ago this
weekend at the mgm grand which we now
know is bally's
hector mejia is live this morning along
the las vegas strip to explain how that
tragedy helped save
shape national safety standards hector
good morning
good morning john and strip hotels are
now built as some of the safest
in the entire world the fire from 1980
led to new safety requirements
valley strip behind me used to be the
site of the original mgm grand
here's a look back in time 1980 as a
witness describes the chaos
people are waiting to be instructed the
ones that are hanging out there the
windows are waiting i don't know how
many are in the halls an electric fire
started in the deli downstairs and then
burst in a fireball through the casino
toxic black smoke went through the hotel
tower while many slept in the rooms
87 people died and more than seven
others were hurt
an automatic fire alarm system was not
in place
unlv gaming historian david short says
it's a tragedy that in the end helped
change fire safety
led to not only a safe for las vegas but
also a safer nation
although it was at a tremendous cost
high-rise construction was still
relatively new at least in the resort
area especially in nevada you know you
just didn't have the idea
also if you look at it other parts of
the country didn't have three thousand
room hotels so you wouldn't have these
issues they would be much smaller
so i think that was one of the reasons
why the regulations lagged
half a year after the fire and he adds
this fire along with the intentionally
set fire at the hilton months later
led to sweeping changes and fire safety
codes mandating sprinklers in all areas
and the fire at the mgm grant from 1980
is in the history books as one of the
worst
high-rise disasters in u.s history
reporting live hector mejia
8 news now all right hector thank you
very much and we'll have more of the
look back at this historical event
coming up over the weekend as well here
on 8 news now alex